the Joe Rogan experience hey tell me
this the creek in the caves the Legion
skanks are not doing yeah what the [ __ ]
they're doing not doing their show at
the creek in the cave anymore first of
all you guys coming to me on this is
worse than Anglin being coming to you
about a Comedy Store but Milo I think
it's directly related yeah yeah I wasn't
quick in the cave right but that's why
there's no they were trying to do it at
the creek in the cave a lady freaked out
right
she buckled under pressure that's not
why they're moving they're already gonna
move it they're already gonna move it
there's new stand was opening up though
they'll use this as an excuse maybe or
people will say that's the reason to do
already gonna move it which start from
the beginning for someone who doesn't
know you're talking yeah there's a boats
Legion skanks you know who they are
and Louise right Louise yeah and uh
Louise Gomez and uh Dave Smith and they
they're hardcore guys except when they
come on this park has it kind of us out
but like hardcore guys for the most part
and so they booked yeah they're they
bitched out oh yeah I don't understand
that I thought we just had a
conversation that's [ __ ] imagine
jackass in the heyday of jackass and
them all sitting here politely and not
trying to [ __ ] shave their heads at
confront it's like come on dirt
obviously they need a second chance on
this project Asians come up and do
something crazy they just came here had
a good time with you yeah nice cotton
nice conversation funny innopolis and
Milo said they cooked out so now he's
running with the narrative so they
booked Milo no I go we have this guy
who's been [ __ ] out whatever and then
uh and then everyone started going doing
the thing with the attack the venue if
you have that problem it's not enough
that they can miss analyze the person or
say I want nothing to do with that guy
then if you put him up then you're the
issue a woman who's gave birth to tons
of [ __ ] great LGB a and [ __ ] black
performers she's an issue because she's
not stopping a a performance from
happening and then soon it'll be like if
you perform at that venue then you're an
ass way right right you know it's
nonsense when he won
happening yeah what's the AC or a
lesbian gay bisexual Alliance oh they
have a lot more since I love college but
that's what I was told oh yeah that's
the problem is when you looked at LGBT
which is like the accepted use of those
letters we in the end we were like oh a
is now asexual and Finn Taylor does a
great joke where it's like they're
included but because the reality is the
asexuals hate the other ones like you're
disgusting okay what sex are a lot of
lesbians you're not really excited about
transgender men or transgender women
rather true there's that there's turfs
you know trans exclusionary radical
feminists no I don't know busy [ __ ]
living my life for now [ __ ] you trying
to dominate or try to dominate I didn't
know you were trying down there wait can
you fill me in more on this though so
tell me about domicile with let's not
leave dominating I'm gonna write that
down but there was a big uproar a lot of
comedians started trying to like show
how they were woken up and they were
like I don't think you should do it who
a ping we're very publicly quit putting
Rebecca in this position telling the
guys innopolis was gonna be in here's
how you can tell someone is a [ __ ]
white knight virtue signaler when they
don't go to you saying hey Tom I'll call
you on the phone you don't do this but I
get it I might not have your number so
if I'm tweeting at you I'll just write
at Tom Segura don't do this if I really
want to purchase signal I'll go dot at
Tom Segura hey at Tom Segura it's not
just me and your followers and everybody
anytime anybody sees if you're listening
you see somebody not start with the app
that is then virtuous signaling on
purpose and also our comics unless
they're saying something positive they
just want to have sure oh yeah
absolutely that's right good point like
hey everybody come see Tom you know yeah
you don't say
Steve sophiar I loved your new Netflix
special yeah don't let the Jew our yeah
thank you it's great it's great our
everyone I saw some of our your Jew
buddy Milo he's gonna appear on the show
all these comics all these people start
saying I'll never go to the creek again
it put unbelievable pressure on her they
call my not some club owner Jewish and
he's also married to a gay man who's
black
yeah who's black washes his ass
opens it originally so wait a minute
what ends up happening so they go we're
not gonna have okay so they said we're
doing this we're not talking they
started going to war with these [ __ ]
virtual signal or comics okay and then
at some point the Rebecca I talked to
our budget I know it's not my thing I
don't even want to do it and I'm a Becca
what you do is you stand by your comics
and so you let them do whatever they
want they say I've been on the loot me
have down the wrong so I've had venues
cancel me yeah cuz if [ __ ] like this so
I'm like you don't wanna be involved
then milos people said oh guys you put
out the the time and date of where I can
see I can't go anymore so they moved it
so they moved it and so did it and still
did it somewhere else yeah we did it and
then okay shout-out to her for not cave
and then yeah it canceled their names
the curricular cave did it go out yeah
okay
yeah and it's it's it's all I did watch
whole thing but the part with you am I
love porn but it was it was pretty funny
the next time somebody calls Milo and
Nazi and me and Nazi sympathiser this
hits my face
holy maybe I'm just weird cuz I just saw
my dad speak at the memorial but I'm
like if you're gonna tell me the people
who took his father and so you need to
say goodbye to your son and so you got
to take care of the family now and watch
the rest of your family if I can
disappear and death is the same as that
political analyst I'm gonna slap you you
should slap yeah I should it's it's so
it's so so derogatory and offensive in a
way that I'm not okay with it so you can
say that away from me but if you say it
to me I'm gonna there's a lot of [ __ ]
from the Sharks that were saying that
yeah it's not enough for those guys
you're getting smacked yes was not gonna
that's what he has always said there's
really good some DJ's delirious
delirious what is completely ridiculous
it's insane it was crazy is a
provocateur yeah he [ __ ] with people he
pushes buttons and he does so in the age
of the internet yeah he's a great troll
the thing that they got him on which is
where it all got really weird was
essentially him saying that it should be
okay what happened to him when he was
molested that he was abused sexually
molested by priests and this priest he
you know
he would joke around and say that he was
the one who pursued the priest that he
was trust me I was the predator like
that's that's how he said it it's he's
hilarious and that's what got him it was
talking about that on my show and then
talking about it on this other show
wasn't it the amazing atheist show was
right the point is that anybody who says
like you shouldn't be allowed to put
that person she can't be heard anymore
that's what you're saying but that's
what it was but it was really just his
harsh critiques of liberals and
feminists that were so biting and then
you know he actually did a podcast with
Jordan Peterson recently we talked about
the the molestation I didn't see it but
from Jordans explanation it's like he's
understanding now as he's getting older
that yeah he was a victim of this thing
he was making it less and less actual
yeah yeah that he was giving this guy
like like a pass that he did it to him
almost yeah